hey guys oh wait listen did you hear
that that is the sound of something you
might have missed when you went through
the ivory crown DLC for the first time
it's also the sound of me not taking any
damage from headshots which is arguably
a pretty pointless bonus as far as
headpiece bonuses go but the point of
what I'm getting at is that it's a
hidden bonus and what's interesting is
that many other items you would have
picked up in your ivory crown
playthrough actually have hidden effects
so let's talk about those for number one
for example did you know that the loss
Armour set that you get actually gives
you a bit of health back every time you
kill something and even if you did know
that the really weird thing is that it
only gives you this bonus if you are a
female character male characters won't
get this bonus so this isn't a problem
for me because I play mainly female
characters but it could easily be a
problem for you next up is the curved
nil grade sword and the description
tells us that the father the wielder
travels the more powerful the blade
becomes so what does this actually
translate into in terms of gameplay well
after a bit of testing we realized that
the nil grade sword actually becomes
more powerful depending on what level of
New Game+ you're in reaching a maximum
attack rating in New Game+ 9 it also
gives you a character this red glow that
will remind you of the old Sun ring
moving on from number 1 the second thing
you might have missed is actually a bit
of an easter egg you should know which
characters clothing this set resembles
if you've played demon souls and if you
haven't played demon souls then the
north water scent is almost certainly a
reference to sage frake visually their
clothing is very similar and the
description even says that it's assert
worn by sages all right third thing you
might have missed is regarding our sauna
who is the 3rd queen of dark now this is
one of the more fairly known ones but
hopefully I can inform a few people who
might have missed it because it's a damn
good one
you will have noticed that the lost
soldiers down below drop boys Souls and
even after you've defeated this boss you
can continue to farm these guys for
their souls because these souls have a
purpose for every 10 you collect our
sauna will shatter or
Oh of ice leading to her person so
collect 50 yeah you have to collect 50
souls and alsanna will present you with
her own soul as well as the silver Louis
Armour set I really like the meaning
behind doing this our sauna is an
embodiment of fear right and as such
we're slowly getting her to trust us and
she's removing these barriers to her
person really carefully you know she's
doing it one step at a time because she
seems to be quite fearful and quite shy
the ivory King vos armor will also be
available from Mall and after you get
her soul and as a final note it is
possible to kill al sana from below with
arrows but doing this makes you a
terrible person so maybe you shouldn't
do that oh and also she won't give you
the Knights armor if you do that so she
will just give you her soul that's worth
mentioning to you terrible person the
fourth thing you missed has to do with a
ladder and it leads to the spell
splintering lightning spear now the
spell is pretty terrible but what's
interesting is the ladder itself the
ladder can be found here and you can't
see it until you get the eye of the
priestess but that doesn't mean you
can't climb it and finally let's finish
with the talk about these horses so some
great testing was done by a guy called
Celica over on reddit who uncovered the
rules that these horses spawned by one
will spawn if you run the wrong way from
the starting area three will spawn
between each ruin with 100% certainty
ten will spawn between the third ruin
and the boss which is correctly labeled
the murder zone and additionally these
horses will only spawn when the
snowstorm is active so since this is
widely renowned as one of the most fun
areas in the game I decided to make it a
little bit more fun for people you know
as a pillar of this community I think
it's important to set an example you
want to be something others can strive
to be I also figured that from software
put these barrels here for a purpose a
reason and what sort of person would I
be if I didn't play the way from
intended I was stalking people for so
long until I actually pulled this off so
it's not like I ruined to that many
playthroughs but I definitely ruined
this guy's playthrough
so if you can get over the atrocity I
just committed then please give the
video a like if you learned something
new and the dislike if you didn't learn
anything this is part of the game we
play and it's actually interesting to
use the like and dislike system as more
of a tally system you know so I'll see
you guys in the next one where we'll be
discussing the ending you get when you
collect all three crowns I have a fair
bit to say on that and yeah see you guys
next time thanks for watching